well with one of my favorite people in
the world Demetrius Johnson Demetrius
with the Demetrius Johnson the community
center welcome to the show it's always a
pleasure to be with you man real it
really is Demetrius you've been doing a
lot of work in the community with your
with your community center now I see you
sporting the Demetrius Johnson
charitable foundation that's beautiful
with the chest and the logo in the
middle and please tell us about that
that's new you haven't told me about
that well so I'm on a team now I'm on a
chess team right you know I always want
to be one of those cerebral thinkers and
be able to get things done so we partner
partner up with the st. Louis chess club
here and we've created football players
and different kids in the community to
learn how to play chess so it's been
very you know very rewarding to these
young men and women because now they
have an opportunity to do things
understand when you make a move here how
can affect your decisions down the road
that was very important to us in the st.
Louis chess club got involved with us I
got a joy Bray she really jumped on
board and I'm telling what matt has
really taken it to another level in
terms of a thinking process of what's
going on in our community we need
something that slow the process down
well tell tell everyone you know this
this idea that that chess and football
are connected you and I know about that
I'm a football fan I know you played for
the line the Detroit Lions for several
years you were a star here was at at
mizzou universe that you were started uh
you were you just you know big in the
community and you've come back to give
back to them and also to teach the
coaches that chess can help their
players play football tell us about that
when we had an opportunity to sit down
with you some months ago and you kind of
Illustrated how important that is to us
how we can make the parallel with chest
and life and football because when you
look at the the front line you equated
that with the chest piece we talked
about the skill players you chest that
with the palms and the bishops and you
know the king and a night who's the
quarterback and all that good stuff so
there is a true parallel of how it
interacts with one another because when
they make it miss a block you can get
your quarterback hurt so when you make a
move on a chessboard guess what happened
you can get you can lose so it's very
important that time they be able to
slowly thinking process down
understand what happens if you do
something that just translate over to
everyday work absolutely and you were
telling me that you have some new
initiatives you you know you're supposed
to stay in touch with me brother you
know yes so many new initiatives going
on tell me this one you just told me for
we came on the air what you're doing at
your communities yeah well we just
started a program will it start a
program six months ago with what we call
our district council 58 painters and we
got young men and women learning how to
paint learning the skill of paint and
they've going to the apprenticeship
program after a 14-week commitment now
the 14-week commitment is this they
don't get a dime they got to be there at
seven o'clock in the morning they got to
work out I'll get their mind get the
whole body just a holistic movement and
after that they go through the process
and they get a job in the going to the
apprenticeship program then we just
started our maintenance housekeeping
janitorial program and we're partnering
with lhm lodging hospitality management
and what that does is teach the young
men who don't have a GED who don't have
a high school diploma to understand the
hospitality industry so we're creating a
workforce for the hospitality industry
and get these young men and women
opportunity to get a job plus they got
to go back and do they GED plus they got
to learn how to play chess wow I'm
telling you man it's been great it had
is fabulous stuff you know with all the
challenges people hear about st. Louis
issues happening in Ferguson we know
that there's a lot of great things
happening here in the city and you're
absolutely doing it with your foundation
which your community center we
appreciate you brother thank you so much
I can do without guys like use important
tricks and the whole team here in the
st. Louis chess club just allowing us
and believing in the movement of the
holistic movement of making a change in
life's people and I got to thank
everybody let me add my good friend Jeff
frankford man he pushed me to get
involved in chest because I was like
apprehensive a man Chasma I don't know
but since I got involved man looking
mean you're worried about Chester little
are some big time nowadays I made it to
the top made of heavy man all right well
I know you want me on your radio show
tomorrow tomorrow morning not me eight
o'clock in the morning eight o'clock
it's tough for a chess player no no no
now count me in i'll be there not for
you I've never heard nobody make chest
sounds so exciting like a super bowl oh
man I'm thinking I'm sitting at the
Superbowl big fella
sorry I'm pumped let me tell you I
thought to be around you every well if
you don't know I love this man and I'll
be awake all right way I'm going out
dancing tonight probably but i'll still
be awake what can I did I go and dance
don't you pick down course you're
invited two right feet I'm just let me
know Demetrius Johnson of the Demetrius
Johnson community center doing
absolutely fantastic work here in st.
Louis in the community wonderful guy
he's making change Thank You Maurice
Demetrius I got a question I gotta flip
back out to you are you familiar with a
movie out of New Zealand called the Dark
Horse features a Maori warrior trying to
bring chess to the community and the
challenges that that man faced and the
whole community face did you see any
parallels if you're familiar with the
movie yeah I am familiar with the movie
and how at first people would
apprehensive about you know the
community that prehensile about that
that movement thinking the chess could
not make a difference and allowing it to
take place it just show you when you
open your mind up and you get to
challenge for something different in
your life things can happen all of its a
beautiful million it's great I loved it
I did I did have my opportunity to watch
it hey nice day well check that out
everyone Demetrius Johnson anytime you
want to be on the show mom and I love it
all right back to you